a little bit about me first I've been an
AR user for around six years I first
learned at Rice University where I went
for undergraduate I'm currently a data
scientist at data camp I started just
two weeks ago for those of you who
aren't familiar with them they're a data
science online education company and
they're sponsoring this conference you
can go learn more about them at the
booth and a couple things I enjoy
talking about if you find me at lunch or
in the coffee breaks a be testing the
talk I gave at Jared's meetup was all
about online experimentation I did a lot
of it at Etsy where I was before and
currently helping data camp build out
their platform building and finding data
science community this is really why I
enjoy being at conferences like this
because all the talks are recorded which
is great for those who can't make it so
you could see these talks but really
it's the energy in the room it's the
connections that you make when you see
people and the coffee and the lunch that
makes it so much fun to be here and
finally of course are alright I have
three goals for my talk today the first
is to keep you hip to the lingo so I'm
talking about the tidy verse but but
what is this tidy verse you know what
how did it come about and who are the
people behind it and the second is to
stop you from doing this we've all had
those moments where we know exactly what
we want our data set to look like how we
want to reshape it or the model and it
just won't work hoping to help solve
that by teaching you some useful
functions you can start doing right away
in your workflow and finally point you
to some resources I'm hoping at the end
of this talk you'll be excited to learn
even more about the tidy verse after
understanding better its its breadth and
how the functions can work with your
data analysis process and I want to help
you start that journey so that will be
the closing part of this talk all right
the tidy verse tidy verse is a set of
our packages that are designed to work
really well together and to bring you
through the data analysis process this
is what the tidy verse universe looks
like most of us are probably familiar
with these steps first you have to even
get your data into R then you work on
changing it maybe you have to munch some
dates probably you'll try it out some
visuals
Asians plotting your data hope Lewis
ggplot2 and then the final step is
usually to communicate it to other
people you might do that through a shiny
interactive dashboard or an arm markdown
document that you make to a Google Doc
that you share with stakeholders and
what we see throughout this process is
written below the big steps import
transform are just some of the tidy
verse packages that can help you through
this now most of you here are probably
familiar with this man he is gonna be
speaking had Lee Wickham for those of
you don't know who's the author behind
such packages as deep liar and ggplot2
and if you've been around in our for a
few years you might have heard the term
the Hadley verse talking about these
packages so a question could be is a
tidy verse just the Hadley versus just
Hadley Wycombe the answer is absolutely
not yeah this is the first time I think
I've had having in the audience for this
but what I wanted to show with this is
that hobbies done a great job starting
this but here are some of the packages
in the tidy verse and these are the
people behind them in some cases they're
the creators of the package in other
cases they're the current maintainer or
active developers without whom the
package wouldn't look like how it is
today and that's what I really wanted to
emphasize is it's grown you know much
beyond one person and really now there
are lots of contributors lots of
packages in the tidy verse and it makes
it a really exciting place to be the
main part of my talk is going to be this
demonstration I'm gonna walk through and
exploratory data analysis of cattles
data science and machine learning survey
this was something they did in 2017 they
surveyed about 16,000 people ranging
from those just starting in data science
to people already in the field asking
questions on their demographic
information what are their favorite
learning platforms or what machine
learning methods are they excited about
next year and some steps of a data
analysis work fall walkthrough going
from everything to viewing our data set
initially inspecting some different
columns making plots and maybe
everyone's favorite steps doing
something really cool and new alright so
first up you just type the name of your
data set after you've imported it into
your console and who's ever had this
happen where it just takes over the
whole thing and you're like
oh no what what have I done what
mistakes have I made and what's happened
is you have so many columns and it's
printing all of them out and this is
really not a useful way to view your
data set because it's just completely
taken over in the solution to this is to
use the function as table from the table
package Tibbals our modern data frames
and they've changed a few behaviors
about data frames but one of the great
ones is that they will only print the
first 10 rows and the columns that fit
on the screen so we can see here is
those rest of those columns that were
the rows of those were all printing out
now we just see the column name along
with its type so this is you never have
to worry about that never-ending console
screen again I guess unless you have
maybe 10,000 columns don't do that
next up examine your days as we heard an
earlier talk missing values can be
really important so how do you take a
look and see what those missing values
might be one way you can do it is first
you do this combination of sum and is
dot n a is Don n a will change the
variable country to true or false
depending on whether it's missing then
we sum it and because true evaluates to
1 and false to 0 that gets us the number
of n A's and using deep fires summarized
we can get this so that now we have you
know just a one row data set that's the
number of n A's and it's 0 but how can
we do this for every column I don't want
to be running through each column name
doing this here's where per can come in
so per to me initially it was a very
intimidating package it's all about
functional programming it has a lot of
stuff but I just want to share it with
those who aren't familiar how how you
can start using it and what here I'm
gonna do is map this function sum isn't
a over every column the map underscore
DF says I want a dataframe back so you
have map underscore CHR I want to
character back and that's how you tell
that's and we can see I do get indeed
back a data frame of one row and 228
columns and what's in the row here is a
number of n A's in that column and the
way I've said this is the dot that's in
here says this is where the column
should go this is what I want where I
want you to the function and that little
tilde just stands for an anonymous
function
and this is a really nice way to do
something over every column what's a
problem here let's take a look at gender
select it's said that there were zero
anaise well what do we see here as
humans there are 95 people where it's an
empty string and we recognize that as an
A but R doesn't and are missing so our
missing values aren't actually an A to
solve this we can use D pliers and a F
and this says if it's argument is what
we want to change to n/a in this case we
want to change an empty string to an A
and now if we want to go and look at our
gender select variable we see just as we
would hope the 95 entries RNA next step
let's examine some of our numeric
columns but how can we do this quickly
we're gonna use a combination of deep
higher selective and skim our skin
select if if you're probably you might
be familiar with deep layers select
select if says I only want to select the
columns if a condition is met in this
case that the numeric and then skimmer
skim gives us a really quick overview
this is all this a lot of the summary
information you'd probably want starting
with how many are the missing what's the
mean standard deviation what are the
percentiles and finally probably my
favorite feature the histogram where we
can and we can immediately start seeing
some things like oh we might have a data
quality issue because age the minimum
age is zero and the maximum is 100
probably we didn't have zero Roald's
taking our survey next let's go back and
examine a single column this is the
column work method select and I'm just
doing a count and I'm seeing ok which
you know let's summarize the data a bit
and see what are the more popular work
method select what's an issue we have
here we can see that this must have been
a multiple selection question so each
row is you know represents like a person
to answer and the problem we have here
is some of the answers have to work
method selected like we see the third
row data visualization common logistic
regression so if we want to understand
what's the most popular work method this
is not a really good format for our data
to be in and to help this we're gonna
use the string or function string
underscore split stringer is all about
working with strings and in this case
we'll see
take that work method select column
split it based on the comma with that
make a new column work underscore method
and let's take a look at that and now
what we have is a column of lists
so that first row is a list is a
character list of five entries and that
used to be five things split by four
commas but now we've got a list but
that's not the format we wanted it to be
in so how can we spread it out so now
once again each row will only have a
single entry and with that we do tidy
our son nests so we take this dataset
which has a list in each row and we
spread it out and we end up with over
60,000 rows because now it's much longer
and with that we can start trying to
visualize so let's make a plot let's do
a plot of you know as we have wanted to
ask what are the most common work
methods and we have a critical issue
with this plot which is it's a mess this
is not helpful right what what what the
heck are are these X's what are the
labels so we're gonna do two things to
solve this the first is a cord flip and
this is really nice you the other option
would be you can make your x axis labels
vertical instead of horizontal but I
personally like the cord flip a lot and
now we can read it and and that's okay
that's more helpful but we still have a
problem they're not ordered so let's
let's order them and with that we can
use for cats was one of my favorite
packages it's around working with
factors and here we're saying okay let's
reorder the work method column by n by
the number of people and now we can see
that oh great this is much easier to
read we see we start data visualization
logistic regression are the most popular
verses like GA ends are all the way at
the bottom not very popular our final
step in a date analysis process right as
we heard is it's maybe just at 5 or 10
percent of time but it's doing something
cool and new and what's the issue we
have here we have no idea what we're
doing so who's running together you're
so excited about a new method and you're
like I don't even know where to start or
I just ran into a bug and why isn't my
code working there's a lot of options
you have here such as reading the manual
but another option is that you can ask a
question
so you and you if you want to make ask a
good question like say on Stack Overflow
our studio community or Twitter a good
way to do is to make a minimal
reproducible example which is all about
helping others help you and we're gonna
do this with two packages table and rep
ryx and first just to clarify a minimal
reproducible example is let's say you
asked a question it says why is in fact
to reorder working would be very
difficult for anyone to answer that for
you so I wouldn't see your code they
wouldn't know what dataset you're
working at but what if your code is a
thousand lines and your data set is
proprietary well you can't really share
that either so a minimal reproducible
example is about reducing your code to
where it's to the shortest possible
amount of code and data that still
illustrates the problem you're having
and this is an optional part but one way
if you need to make a kind of fake data
set to do this you can use Tribble to
make a toy data set in Tribble is how I
always dreamed of making data sets in
art which is just on the first row you
list your column names a little tilde
before it and the next row is just all
the entries and here I'm just saving
that as an original data frame next up
we can use the package reference from
Jenny Brian to find any problems what do
I mean by that let's say we have our
code so on the left here we've said okay
this is the code that's having a problem
let me try rhetorics I copy it and run
ref prax but oh no I'm having errors so
if someone was running this in a clean
our session they would have errors and
not the errors I want them to have but
but the error is because I haven't
loaded the packages so in this case if
we look at what errors are gonna come
out it's oh I don't I can't find the
function business I can't find the
function ggplot we go back to our code
and realize we haven't done the library
calls so rep Rex will help you find
those issues before you post and someone
goes back and says hey I can't run your
code then we can use refworks to post
your question or issue and that's really
nice say in this case we're seeing an
example where you posted it on on github
like maybe you want to file a bug report
with a package and the nice thing is if
formats your code and includes any plots
and makes it really easy just to go and
submit your issue just by copying it
all right so this is just an overview of
what we went through today about 11
functions like I said there are so many
more not just packages but functions
within the packages and that's why I
wanted to go over for example deep wire
which is a very popular package but many
people don't realize the depth of the
functions that it has and at the
resource at the end I'm gonna point you
to some places where you can find out
things like that first Resource is
Hadley wickham's and Garrett Crowe
LeMans are for data science book which
will probably be given away at this
conference it's available for free
online and it's a really good resource
it's appropriate for both beginners so
if you're just starting out in our but
also even for more advanced our users
who are looking either - maybe wholesale
switch into the tidy verse or I've been
using the tidy verse but aren't familiar
with certain parts such as may be
working with dates and then they can go
to this book and just jump to the
chapter or section on that next up is
the our statutory hash tag so I'm a big
Twitter user and one of the reason I
like it is it's a very friendly
community in this case I was saying I
have a what happened was I had a report
that I was writing at Etsy and I had
about 12 plots in it but I was going to
share this with a lot of people so I
wanted to make those plots use the Etsy
color scheme and I knew about theme
underscore set which is a way at the top
of your your script you can set the
background for your plot and that will
change all the plots later but that
didn't work for colors and I wanted to
know how can I change globally change
the colors on my plot without having to
go and every single plot add the color
scale that I wanted an hour so Twitter
came to the rescue
so Alday Sessler here said did you know
about this package GG theme our here's
the functions in it and here's a blog
post I wrote about it and this was a
really nice way to get it get an answer
to my question that the googling hadn't
hadn't done for me
next up our star studio has lots of
cheat sheets you can find them at their
table in the back this is / I like it
again as both a reference but per is
often thought of mainly for its map
function but this is a two-sided cheat
sheet and there's so many more functions
that you have here so whether it's you
want to dive into a package or you want
a one
stop shop for working with strings you
can go to our studio cheat sheets and
find those now of course I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention my company data camp
I actually had this in my presentation
even before I worked with them and
that's part of why I was so excited to
join as I mentioned it's a data science
online education company and it's a
little bit different we have a couple of
things we have projects and problem sets
but one of our main things is courses
and these courses are for hours so
they're a lot shorter than say a
Coursera course which might run over a
few months we have people like you know
Charlotte Wickham Hadley has a course
I'm working on a course right now in
categorical variables and the way these
courses work as you watch videos and
then you do these interactive exercises
right in your browser so it's a nice way
if you're just starting to learn like
our Python or sequel to not have to
download anything and to get immediate
feedback all right
in conclusion I wanted to say again that
you know our has we're great we have as
Kristine thing here is sharing we have
all these awesome stickers again you can
find some of them in the back cool
package names but so maybe maybe that's
how we can help attract people initially
but really staying for the friendly
community and happy workflow and that's
part of why I love so much being part of
the art community I worked with Our
Lady's global organization advancing
gender equality in the art community and
we've had such an outpouring of support
from a lot of other people in terms of
sponsorships and I really think that
just shows that ours is really the
people helping lead our do not want to
be elitist they don't want to exclude
others our is meant for people who in
some cases are never going to be
professional developers but and that's
kind of what the tidy verse is about is
even even if you don't want to go deep
into let's say like advanced programming
which you definitely can and are the
tardy verse gets you doing powerful
things very quickly with that I want to
say you can find my slides very soon on
this link tiny dot CC New York our talk
I blog about some of these topics like
finding data science community making
our faster on my blog hooked on data you
can find me on Twitter Robinson
underscore yes and with that thank you
all so much
[Applause]
you